Abdul Hamid Yusef arrived in Italy ten
days ago after Syrian government forces
captured his hometown kunshi home he is
one of the survivors of a chemical
attack in the same town in 2017 that
killed 25 members of his family
including his wife and their twins after
marrying again he started over but after
receiving death threats from the regime
he is afraid and doesn't want us to film
his wife I couldn't even forget the pain
how can I deal with losing my family and
my homeland each time we say we'll stand
up there's something that breaks us our
hearts either in Turkey or in Europe
Abdul Hamid wants a better life for his
family
I'm living witness of Assad's crimes I
want to tell the world with a Turkish
border to the north sealed
however the displaced in northern Syria
have nowhere else to go as the fighting
intensifies most of these vehicles carry
Syrians fleeing from the south of Italy
border in August the number on the moon
had reached at least 70,000 the influx
causes a huge traffic jam in the only
the overloaded city of Eid Lib and it
takes hours to move just the short
distance especially in the Atma refugee
camp every day there are more of these
makeshift shelters under olive trees and
nuts map close to the Turkish border
having been displaced several times the
average family from Hama only arrived
today the landlord just came and told us
to move shall I pitch my tent on the
road we are displaced left everything
behind tell me now
what can we do the latest regime
operations in northern Hama are putting
health facilities under pressure
hospitals are short of supplies and
staff humanitarian aid is urgently
needed it's a desperate wait for many in
adlib including Abdul Hameed wondering
whether the war will catch up with them
again see namco sólo al Jazeera at
northwestern Syria